hey y'all i'm jerry it's grilling season
it's summer and i love ribs so today i'm
testing out three celebrity rib recipes
to find out which one's the best our
contestants are snoop dogg al roker and
martha stewart all right y'all let's get
to it
first step we have snoop dogg's baby got
back ribs first he has you make an easy
rub brown sugar paprika cayenne pepper
garlic powder kosher salt and black
pepper now i'm just going to give this a
little whisk so now i'm going to apply
the rub so lay it on thick this recipe
calls for a good amount of rub so i'm
going to make sure i'm super generous
with it flip the ribs and just repeat
that same process i just want you to
notice that i removed the membrane from
this side of the ribs and that just
helps with eliminating any toughness as
you bite into the rib now i'm going to
transfer these prepared ribs onto my
aluminum foil wrap them up nice and
tightly our ribs aren't a baking tray
and we're going to put these in an oven
at 300 degrees for one and a half to two
hours or until they're falling off the
bone let's go okay so while our ribs are
cooking we're gonna start on this crazy
simple barbecue sauce ketchup some
apricot jam
and
worcestershire or is it worcestershire
worcestershire sauce we'll go with that
and folks that is it all i'm gonna do is
give it a whisk most barbecue sauces
require some cooking over the stove top
but this is it i'm done here's your
barbecue sauce you're welcome now i'm
gonna catch up on my tik tok our ribs
are out of the oven so i'm going to
carefully remove the foil then transfer
the ribs to the baking sheet so snoop
says to just give it a nice thick
slather of barbecue sauce only on the
top now we're going to bring these guys
for 10 minutes until deeply brown
our ribs are out of the oven i've let
them rest for 10 minutes now i'm going
to cut them in two rib portions
oh you like that huh and we're going to
serve this right on the cutting board
look at that
these are beautiful
the snoop calls for a few things when
you enjoy his ribs lots of napkins
check
barbecue sauce for dipping got it and
white bread this is how i enjoy my ribs
let's see what our taste testers think
let's do it first and foremost
can smell some amazing flavor when i go
to texas like that kind of barbecue work
they give you the white bread and then
just like a whole slab of ribs looks
like it's sauce just right not too much
not too little definitely see the char i
hope i can taste the char i feel like i
can smell the char all right so let's
try these oh my gosh look at that
pulls right off the bone dip it in the
sauce do it how they do it in the south
this is certified this is good i don't
think i would improve anything this is
pretty spot-on it's like sweeter than i
was imagining it's not brown sugar
it's tender it's juicy
it falls off the bone i just feel like
in terms of flavor this rib is just not
super memorable mmm
it's gonna be tough to bat after this
this is a pretty good start
so we're gonna start with three racks of
baby back ribs in a roasting pan then
we're gonna reserve one cup of ginger
ale so i've braised with soda before
specifically with like spry and seven up
and this helps with the caramelization
of the meat due to all the sugars in the
soda so next we're going to season it
with kosher salt and we're going to add
water just until the ribs are covered
i'm going to put these in the oven at
300 degrees for two to three hours or
until they're falling off the bone and
i'm going to make sure to flip them
halfway through let's go
now we're going to work on al's barbecue
sauce first thing we're going to do is
add brown sugar ketchup
soy sauce
sweet chili sauce and our reserved one
cup of ginger ale we're going to mix
this together and now we're going to
bring this to a low boil and then cook
it for about 10 to 15 minutes or until
it thickens our sauce has been cooking
for about 15 minutes it's reduced by
about half it's beautiful look at that
color we're going to take this over to
our preheated grill slather it with
delicious barbecue sauce let that cook
for a few minutes flip it and then let
it do its thing again these ribs smell
amazing they are falling apart falling
off the bone now we're gonna take these
ribs off the grill y'all these ribs look
so good look at this they look and they
smell amazing these are my kind of ribs
let's see if our taste testers agree
looking at the grill marks you can see
the char on the ribs which looks really
nice i can see a little bit more sauce
on these ones i'm ready to go i'm ready
to dig in oh yeah oh yeah
that's what i want oh my god
this is good this is good this is good
it's a little bit harder to get off of
the bone gotta find the perfect bite
i like the sauce on this one a lot and
the meat's just like melting in your
mouth so
it's a solid rib it's like melty
like actually melts in your mouth i'm
not getting as much sweetness this time
i'm getting a smokiness whereas last
time i think i needed the bread to add
that like extreme element this is good
as is i think i like these ones
whoops
this is exactly
what i want in a barbecue rib
i mean are you eating ribs if you don't
like your lick your fingers i don't know
how you choose between but this is a
solid ribber
all right y'all we're in our last recipe
and it's martha stewart's oven roasted
ribs martha has you using a whole lot of
ribs her recipe calls for using baby
back or st louis style so here we have
four racks of st louis style ribs we're
gonna start off by making a rub so we
have some paprika brown sugar kosher
salt cayenne pepper we have cocoa powder
which i've never tried in a rub before
but i feel like it'll add a little
complexity to it and cumin use a spoon
the back of the spoon and kind of just
push it through i'm gonna give this a
good whisk before we
place this rub onto our ribs sprinkle
this on top of all the ribs flip these
bad boys over and then repeat the same
step get that rub really into the meat
so these ribs are ready to go i'm gonna
cover them with plastic and martha says
to marinate them for 20 minutes to two
hours but i want maximum flavor so i'm
going to put these in the fridge for two
hours so now we're going to work on the
barbecue sauce which i think is a little
extra we've got a lot of ingredients
here so first we're going to add a
little bit of oil to this pot over
medium-low heat then we're going to add
our onions
and garlic saute that just until the
onions are translucent add cumin some
cayenne cook this for a minute just to
let these spices bloom for a bit add
some tomato paste cook this up for a
minute and add the rest of the
ingredients kicking it off with a little
black pepper some kosher salt brown
sugar and some apple sauce
okay apple cider vinegar
i don't know how i feel about that yet
and apple juice
and our last ingredient is crushed
tomatoes
give this a good stir i'm gonna bring it
to a boil then drop it to a low simmer
then i'm gonna partially cover it and
simmer it for two hours
so it's been two hours we're gonna check
on our sauce now give it a good
okay honestly that smells a little bit
like marinara sauce let this cool we're
going to transfer it to a blender get it
nice and smooth and then we're going to
work on our ribs all right y'all these
ribs have been marinating for two hours
and as you can see the color is deep
it's rich so we're going to put them in
the oven at 350 degrees for one and a
half to two hours or until the ribs fall
off the bone these bad boys are fresh
out of the oven slather both sides of
barbecue sauce pop them in the oven at
425 and boil them for 15 minutes
okay martha's ribs are done all we have
to do is cut them up plate them and eat
so we've plated these ribs it smells a
lot like pasta in here but let's see
what our taste testers think
what is this what am i looking at right
now this is crazy these ribs look
different
they are bigger these do not look like
baby back baby back baby back this is
different looking it oh wow yeah okay so
st louis style all right let's dig in
shall we oh thick thick
heavy heavy i'm like really nervous for
some reason right now
oh i'm not a fan i don't like the sauce
it tastes like tomato sauce the meat's
too chewy i don't like it yeah i'm not a
fan first thoughts
great impactful flavor good punch there
at the beginning but i wish that it was
a little juicier a little tender and i
just you know i'm all about the fall off
the bone experience
well um okay
so
what is that is that
like a curry ketchup what that tastes
strange i think it's a pepper is it a
pepper no
i do like these i thought that i was
gonna get a little spice out of them and
i didn't but
that's okay these have a more vegetable
vibe i don't know it tastes like pasta
sauce and so we're dipping ribs
in pasta sauce this is a frankin food of
this one and no offense to the creator
of this i probably would not eat this
one again and that's really sad to say
because
you're supposed to love all ribs equally
so my favorite was the second one i
think that one just for me stood out the
most shut up ow hey good for you buddy i
didn't even know al roker had recipes al
killing it in the rib game who knew my
favorite ribs if it wasn't obvious
already
is number two al roker
fake fan al
nice job so my favorite was definitely
number two number one was like a close
second like it was just behind it but i
like the sauce better my man al roker
you got it right brother you got it
right my favorite ribs hands down were
right in the middle number two it didn't
need bread it didn't need extra sauce
everything was there and the flavor
worked together really well the texture
was there it was crunchy it was awesome
what
the weather person sunny with a chance
of pork chops all right y'all it's
unanimous everyone said al's sticky
ginger ale ribs are the best so you know
i gotta try it
okay these are these are amazing these
are good and they would be great to
bring to a block party speaking of block
party that's the name of the new movie
from buzzfeed studios now streaming on
bet plus check it out see you next time
thank you for being here bye y'all
oh yes
[Music]
you